game four of a four-game road trip for the Flames
they're two and one so far wins in Minnesota and
Nashville a lot of Central Division opponents
on the schedule for the Flames now it's Tor he
has Blackwell up ice Colin Blackwell stops on
the dot shoots he scores let him know CB one
nothing Hawks New York his first goal of the
year and then here he goes busting down the
left side a little cut back move right there
and he just fires this High into the bar and
in and thanks for coming what a shot a little rer
right there maybe a slight screen on Dan badar the
goendale red coaching staff in the line and have
a good conversation early Jonathan hubero looking
for a man in front and Calgary scores a crash
play at the net to get their attention keep
your eye on that if possible here huor going
down the wing and did LOL push that pad right
there and causing the puck he by by his tip
of his blade pushing the pad in it interferes
with his Pad right there and then the puck
comes loose so it doesn't go in originally it
goes in on the ensuing play right there the
stick blade pushing the pad Puck's not over
the over the goal line yet if it continues
on then I don't think there's no chance I'm
going to stop it right there so right at
this point here it's pushing the puck uh
the pad excuse me in now the Puck's not over
the goal line yet as you can see after video
review determined that there was go gender
interference we have no goal all right now
cadri Murphy and posil meet Isaac Phillips
has it Stripped by Cadre looking for Zer and
now Hanahan a shot Cadre the redirect with
a wide open net that one will count what a
play by Hanahan I mean everyone in the building
thought he was going to fire that puck from the
left P it towards the far post and once this Puck
goes around keep your eye on the defenseman there
and here I'm thinking he's going to shoot it
and how he finds its way through the body of
Murphy Murphy's obviously anticipating that as
well and it finds its way through the heel the
stick and the skate blade of Murphy and right on
the tape right there to Cadre who's got one skate
in the crease and and now Zer Zer on the goal
line back to Anderson Zer it's lindol the man
down low Zer in tight and the puck kicked out
into the slot Kev classic top of the circle he
passes for Reichel Donado in front and the puck
bounces to the Calgary bench looking at that
here's Tori kachuk to the net rebound save
ladar and hubero banked up to the point
weager shoots fasic made a play with the
glove no one knows where the puck is it was
on his left pad and it's still up for grab
yeah it was underneath his left pad and he
swung it around to his right weager hubero
across to the Sur blocked by Murphy and a goal
for Calgary just throw that puck towards the
front of the net and how many times do you see
this in the National Hockey League as he turns
around and he spins him right round baby right
round and then here's the shot right off the
skate I mean the angle of the skate of Murphy
right there I mean perfectly unfortunately for
Murphy and the Hawks directs it right into the
net as he makes his turn you can see Murphy in
front of the now he turns and he's likely
think Anderson for weager Dylan duay lost
the puck Cole Gutman here we go from the left
Circle Gutman save Dan Vadar off the Stick of
glassic glassic nudges the puck Over the Line to
Center glassic Gutman centers Gutman back to the
net he turns and shoots classic oh boy Savvy
you know was fun with being just a teammate
of Savvy in practice cuz he kept you on your toes
here's Dickinson looking for KF kurf turns fires
scores we are [Applause]
tied offensive zone face off and it's one
cleanly terrific play they're down the left
boards and that's vasic and it got a little
bit of a break CU it goes off weager skatey
can't find it and kers just turns spins
and then it goes off the Stick of Rasmus
and Anderson so there's the break off the
skates and here's the break off the stick
finally the Hawks getting some bounces
and breaks Kev for Dickinson Blackwell
sweeps it up toward the line to Nordy now
off a stick of career and Zev to The Net
score that puck pinballed around and
the Hawks get another to take the lead
[Music]
right point shot right off the skate and
again as I mentioned before zitb likes
to pull the puck he's not shooting this to
score he's shooting it for the redirection
the high slot but it goes under the stick
and raid off the Stick of D Simone and the
skate blades are pointing gone over the glass
and into the stands from the defensive Zone
cor chinsky tries to threat it for
Zev but a chance for backland and
a big save by moric Anderson as the
Hawks begin to Tire backland pushed
by Zev battling for the puck in front
man japani below the goal line off the
back of moric holy [Applause] smokes
raspas Anderson deflected by blassic
backland in front save mezic rebound from Coleman
they just told me hey we think you could use dance
lessons and I showed up didn't really know what I
was getting into as you can tell so the Hawks Up
3 to two as we begin the third period And there's
a shot from Lucas reel Anderson cadry shoots save
moric rebound Swept Away by Peter let see if
the H can get up there with some speed here 20
seconds left on the power play zeep drills it in
Sanford on the opposite way Blackwell shoots he
scores Johnny on the spot Colin Blackwell
his second goal of the day one last chance
at it that's why you you never give up it's
another fortunate bounce right there it goes
along the boards off duay skate and right to
the slot it's like a perfect pass and it ends
up on Blackwell's tape and again he fires this
to the glove side that's the second time he's
beaten the go tender well Calgary two points out
of wildcard positioning going into today with 39
points in the Western Conference there's a drive
from Anderson with hubero down low cadri off the
side of the net and Calgary scores a puck that
went off the glove and stayed alive quick play
these are just Instincts by by cadri he's on
the right side of your screen there's the one
that off the glove and you can see huor plays
that right to the goal line in the left-handed
cadri with great calmness here he looks at the
clock immediately the pass went off to Nory skate
that is the theme of this afternoon's game here
the bounces off the skates and right to the tape
as you can see right there hubero plays it off
the toe of the skate right to cadri I I don't
understand the instincts of Sharon goic outside
the circle now backland Sharon govic Hanahan
Sharon goic fires off the skate of blassic moric
makes the save on backland Dickinson tapped by
blassic to the line 7 seconds left it's [Music]
pin shot blocked and out of play the horn sounds